Music's a very personal experience.
It means something different to everyone.
The first time I saw the prototype, I was astonished like anyone else...
...because there's something levitating above the surface that doesn't happen in nature.
We're also including the latest technology inside the final version of the OM/ONE.
We're using Bluetooth 4.0....
...which can basically pair with most devices that are out there today.
Another really cool thing about Bluetooth 4.0...
...is that you can stereo pair two OM/ONEs together...
...and it just makes for an incredible audio experience.
There's also a Type 1 microphone in the orb, so you can use it as a speakerphone.
We actually use it all the time for conference calls and meetings.
And the orb has a 15-hour battery life.
So when you take it with you, it requires no recharging.
It truly, truly is a revolutionary piece of hardware.